reading Oh lots of reading and legalese
reading at that
honestly all this robot law reading
bullshit might as well just be
production logos that's how much
attention I'm paying it also all these
laws seem to only revolve around bodily
harm or death to humans and nothing else
maybe Isaac Asimov watched the purge and
Futurama back to back I'm not sure but
you think he put something else in there
regarding ethics
God gave us humans ten laws and only one
of them was don't hurt each other name
character wakes up from a nightmare
cliche incorrectly eating pie also it's
alarming how easily this movie is
opening few minutes of Will Smith doing
could substitute for the opening few
minutes Will Smith doing bid and I am
Legend alarming I tells you also
showering without a shower curtain how
does anything stay dry in that bathroom
into hell out in my face can you can
hate robots that's fine but don't you
want your package honestly like let's be
truthful with each other here that hat
is the worst thing about this movie and
yes I know the movie is a giant turd
that's how bad that hat is excuse me so
main characters disdain for robots
absolutely hammered home by the 4-minute
mark if you've come for subtlety oh hell
no also if the robots have all the jobs
what's the unemployment rate like in
2035 closing in on 50% goddamnit young
Shia LeBeouf dragged this movie into him
did he stop cussing cuz you're not good
at it that's for sure but still he said
let me borrow your damn ass keys which
is more an assault on basic grammar than
it is an assault on cussing actually he
barely even cussed whatever I already
hate this movie
thanks going movie at the beginning of
Spooner's sneaky crawl he's only at the
second opening in the hallway but as
soon as Gigi says you talk to Marcy he
makes it all the way to the stairs
making Spooner the fastest stealth
crawler in the world congratulations
when I was coming up we didn't just
marry someone then divorce them then not
talk to them uh old granny you're as
stuffed with x position as you are old
potato pie why the hell does he keep
eating pie like this I don't know I
don't live in the future but isn't
assuming a running robot carrying a
purse is a thief kind of a huge leap in
logic
stop this robot is violating the second
law you've already forgotten the laws
you say me too this is a long-ass
parking garage I think it's about time
we recognized Will Smith's Tom Cruise
likability to run in most of his movies
men in black man in black - I am Legend
iRobot bad boys bad boys - and he made
the state Hancock Suicide Squad you
alright
character development via eyewitnesses
but since she's right I'm mostly ok with
this he is an asshole how many robots if
ever / - first to be fair snatching a
purse is not in violation of any of the
laws theft isn't technically harmful and
when you're a robot everything is
technical discounts Dark Tower Khalifa
I'm sorry my responses are limited you
must ask the right question dr. Lanning
programmed his response hologram to be
just ambiguous enough to move the plot
forward just a little bit during each
interaction because nothing makes a
movie more interesting than a scavenger
hunt why would you kill yourself that
Detective it's the right question yet we
still don't receive an answer program
terminated
how and why did you record a program of
your future interaction with a detective
investigating your death before I'll
forget it this movie's IMDB score is low
enough I bet I can fake my way through
this genre for the coffee sugar ah oh
you thought I was calling you sugar
ladies and gentlemen comedy uh maybe you
simply would have banned the internet to
keep the libraries open you mother
fuckers closed the library's monsters
that's the most fucked up thing in this
entire movie lawrence told me to
accommodate you in any way possible
really being pretty rapey
little-known fact tom brady left
girlfriend and baby mama Bridget
Moynahan for Gisele because of how bad
this movie turned out true story Danny
Amendola told me apologies there appears
to be data corruption so no video of the
suicide murder great
might as well be set in the 50s based on
the evidence he has to go on also
Spooner who has been overly suspicious
of everything thus far glosses over the
data corruption excuse without any
further questioning or investigating
every time he puts on the Hat this
mother takes the extra time to ensure
the left side is covering 30% of his ear
and it's maybe the most annoying thing
ever
not having vertigo not these laws
they're hardwired into every robot how
are they hardwired exactly are there
three separate first second and third
law wires that are installed a robot can
no more commit murder than a human could
walk on water you know there was this
one guy
stealing the if he's not guilty why did
he run motive from every episode of
Matlock ever holy robots constructed to
serve coffee and B Butler's were also
constructed to survive 18 story jumps
and mostly I'm just asking why he got
down here that fast King no not bloody
likely
Jesus thank God he hit the whatever with
his bullet that conveniently drips out
liquid mercury one drop at a time so he
could track this thing I mean imagine if
that hadn't happened you've heard it
badly badly is an adverb meaning that
the method Will Smith used to hurt the
robot was poor when what you mean to say
is that the robots wounds are severe do
you see me on the phone all the more
reason you shouldn't be driving
audible skidding sounds from a hovering
car so where is everybody this facility
was designed built and it's operated
mechanically so are you the first humans
ever to set foot here
where are the checks and balances people
I want to trust robots as much as the
next guy but I can't do that as long as
I know you're letting them run this free
I give robots super-strength you're just
asking for an army of passionless
creatures that can't be defeated all of
those swamp team bullets managed to miss
insert stormtrooper joke here all those
bullets and you simply needed to think
like spider-man to bring him down what
if I'm right after several minutes of
the boss explaining how stupidest theory
was this guy still changes set bosses
mind with a simple one if I'm right if
everyone believes that this robot
doesn't have the capacity to kill then I
guess these six guards are actually just
an acapella group or something my father
tried to teach me human emotions they
are difficult I'm going to choose this
moment here among many to praise Alan
Tariq for his performance in this film
as the robot and we'll take two sins off
a movie I know we'll go on to earn
enough for that to sin reduction to not
affect the ultimate score but still show
respect for an actor who is great can a
robot write a symphony probably yeah
maybe even a kick-ass one I think maybe
your anti robot prejudice is making you
stay some stupid haha super tiny cell
phones of the future imagine struggling
to tell the difference between your
phone and your flash drive that's the
future there isn't some hard kill switch
on these robots even data on Star Trek
had an off button meanwhile at the
Ovaltine kept wait hopeful teen cafe
what the fuck you want to call your
grandmother because I will you know how
cop bosses talk to their detectives
turtle 4650 inflation demolition
scheduled for 8 a.m. Spooner doesn't
question why this is going to be
demolished it's a large mansion still
fully furnished and contains dr.
landings personal materials and possibly
very useful information yet USR is going
to destroy it and no one's going to
worry about it
detective spoon spooner still has access
to landing channels for some reason I've
always been ghosts in the machine roll
croteau
wait wrong movie stored bait it will
smith learn nothing of the usefulness of
cats from his time on men in black this
cat somehow doesn't scratch off Will
Smith's face during the sequence
suggesting the movie has never cat it
this thing just broke through the
hallway window upstairs at a good forty
feet from here not only do I not think
it can move fast enough to be here right
now it also seems to be destroying the
house based on what room Will Smith is
it which is absurd also he survives this
and everything else that happens in this
scene which is some astronomical
bullshit like this for example I mean
did you see that even the cat is James
Bond right now Jesus the English
language has no words for how much this
pissed me off
therefore I will resort to French shakin
City as said it will bless their cool
slow Jack gets it that Connery also most
convenient mote bond ever also this cat
just went through all that and then got
dunked underwater and still has not
clawed out even a single one Will
Smith's eyes also this cat was
definitely covered in water for the sake
of this scene which if you know cats
basically qualifies as animal torture
but as long as no horses were harmed in
the making of this movie I guess we
don't care how does he know where she
lives what happened to you Calvin says
this instead of why are you at my house
we just met this morning and I don't
like it he postulated that every
conversation between these two goes like
this Spooner asks a specific question
Calvin gives Spooner a ridiculously
complicated answer Spooner goes what and
Calvin scoffs and says it normally they
do this because she's a smart person
he's a dumb person and run-time
suggested that robots might naturally
evolve awesome you still went through
with making him look you want something
to be wrong with them this is a personal
vendetta
maybe but as a woman of science that
shouldn't matter he has evidence enough
to form a hypothesis just let him work
it out yep you are the dumbest smart
person I have ever met in my life well
you've clearly never met Kristen I mean
me Chris will be mad if I make that joke
about him but I'm concerned it's not
funny enough if I make it about me
maybe Barret ah Will Smith makes
pretending to drink whiskey look like an
impossible task if robots aren't
supposed to have emotions then why does
this one look so sad yes hello I'd like
to report a complaint regarding my ns5
it keeps giving me seductive looks while
it chops phallic vegetables future
security systems don't need your
fingerprint or your eye scan just the
butt end of a balled up fist
somehow
u.s. our mainframe accessing mainframes
and doing general detective work while
driving at a high rate of speed it's
convenient that there are no other
drivers on this interstate that runs
through urban Chicago so these giant
robot truck could attack in this
formation oh hell no it's not a Will
Smith movie if he doesn't say aw hell no
or I mean damn you think that they'd
come up with a less expensive way to try
and kill Spooner but it seems like they
went with the most expensive way
thankfully for the viewer whenever a
robot has turned evil in this movie his
chest glows red instead of blue and
while the movie has no explanation for
that mine is quite simple the movie
sucks balls and thinks the viewers are
all morons not only is this car spin at
high speed problematic in the world of
logic it also somehow doesn't result in
all the robots flying off which is even
more problematic yeah he's totally
passed down after these excessive
g-forces no question about it except for
the movie totally glossing over it and
keeping him coherent well he's not a
robot and is the main character so I
guess he survives this even though
that's anger inducing levels of bull I
just threw up and that's the sin holy Sh
he's one of them he's one of them and by
that I mean most predictable thing ever
sunny has the Three Laws but he can
choose not to obey them sounds kind of
like the Three Laws don't mean doesn't
it play I guess in the future it's not
rude just to walk into someone's house
and play with her stereo okay he has a
robot arm and that's all great still
doesn't explain his unhinged hatred of
robots or how he was able to spray paint
his arm back together but whatever I'm
wild by your side - movie Sarah this was
hers
so you kept and are wearing the necklace
of one of the victims of the car crash
that cost you your arm yeah that's
normal
Jesus how did you even get this without
stealing it from the morgue so Will
Smith's character hates robots because
they saved him instead of the little
girl fine I understand that motivation
but my question is why did that robot
save him instead of the girl well I know
what they say about old dogs no not
really
right this society has autonomous robots
but hasn't downloaded basic Wikipedia
knowledge into their brain so they can
understand idioms right I had hoped you
would come to think of me as your friend
even though the last interaction they
had sunny tried to kill him he's still
an optimist his name is sunny for
Christ's sake
I'm sorry I'm allergic to bullshit hey
asshole that's my line
I'm so sorry Sonny what are you sorry
about his recent malfunctioning Jesus
movie these are robots and 95% of humans
would not get attached to them lit hurt
why did these humans program this robot
with the concept of pain why the who are
you wearing sunglasses it's a nighttime
dude why is it that when robots are
stored in an empty space they will group
together rather than stand alone why are
they all still on and how did they not
run out of power in those crates the
three laws apparently led to robot chaos
fine but why did said robot chaos begin
without warning and evolved within
minutes into a scene out of gangs of New
York upon seeing a single human these
robots stopped beating up other robots
and collectively chase said human
because reasons why were they beating up
other robots just before this only to
shift into human hating mode on a dime
do they no longer want to be robot ass
as well oh I see half the reject
homeless robots still value human life
while the other half of the ball to
rightfully hate human life do I have
that right why does the three laws
programming only affect infect half the
robot population and reluctantly Bridget
Moynahan signed the divorce papers I
mean contract knowing it contained and
Exploited of steamy shower scene not
gonna lie totally forgot Shia was in
this that's how unimportant his
character is instead of completely wind
blocking or rip breaking this asshole
this robot just punched merely throws
him back 15 yards and causes him to make
a concern facial expression wait when we
last left her she was half naked coming
out of the shower and realizing her
personal robot was going to kill her now
we cut to this the cabin in between this
crowd of stupid humans marching on the
robots has seen V for Vendetta one too
many times
stupid humans forever somehow gets to be
the leader of the impossibly colossal
Chicago Tea mob hasn't that boy lesson
Spooner runs into one of the three
people he knows during the robot riot
some bullsh
this chick fires this machine gun like
this and somehow only hits the bad robot
which is actually preposterous did you
just shoot at me with guys close well I
worked in it here's some more ridiculous
results-oriented thinking just because
it work does not mean it wasn't a
stupidest fucking hell decision sudden
trapdoor entrances both completely out
of nowhere and out of the sight line of
the red robot and a huge fucking ex
machina service areas no surveillance
because why would we ever want to keep
tabs on those servicing our super
high-tech robot lab building 2880 stats
detective movie is telling me they
walked up all those steps without even
being slightly winded or sweaty are we
sure they aren't all robots
this thing's basically the metal baby
face from Matrix Revolutions I would
prefer not to kill dr. Calvin yep this
robot is still human it picked up and
assimilated the wink when your lying
thing from 7th grade kids interactions
Spooner in the gang are able to move
freely in the US our headquarters
despite Vicky's omnipotence just don't
look down don't look down that's for
building planning he's right but that
doesn't mean I'm not gonna send this
movie for this building's poor planning
this works for some reason thank you for
this vertigo-inducing camera swoop guy
who will clearly go on to direct or at
least inspire a ninja turtles movie this
is awesome but why is sunny so much
better fighting than the other robots
again with the Vertigo camera twirl
Jesus Alex Proyas you make good movies
once upon a time got you so obsessed
with a swirly camera because it's
annoying will you make sure dr. Calvin
devolves into Mary Jane Watson by the
finale um what is this glowing center
pillar made of and why can he kind of
grab it and slow his descent and what
does it made of and why does this movie
hate me think that's what dr. Lanning
would have wanted oh the landing who
created a supercomputer that instigated
a robot uprising and killed himself thus
avoiding any moral or legal fallout from
that you know apocalypse scenario yet
planning and sunny became robot Jesus to
the other robots and he saw that it was
good
just what do you think you're doing day
there is a robot in this formation that
does not belong identify it
I am bender please insert girder
eighteen hundred thousand do it over
there got one I can respect that my good
shirt er I'm sorry
give me sugar